un nouveau je dis noir est annoncé
demain un mouvement de grève qui va
toucher la région parisienne le trafic
sera très fortement ralenti à Paris
cette ligne de métro fermée cette
seulement ouverte aux heures de pointe
les RER A et B seront également
perturbés les agents RATP demandent une
hausse des salaires et de meilleures
conditions de travail
et je suis allé mais je suis allé sur le
de la RATP pour essayer de me faire
embaucher et pouvoir un petit peu
quelles sont les conditions comme
proposées aujourd'hui j'ai pas trouvé ça
dégueulasse je veux dire 13ème mois un
salaire de de base brute pour un
conducteur de métro qui est à 2000 un
peu plus un peu plus de 2450 euros
on est d'accord on est ça beaucoup
d'avantages comme par exemple des aides
pour les crèches des aides pour la
mutuelle des aides pour le logement en
fait ce que c'est un mouvement de grève
à la SNCF bonjour parisienne ça concerne
le RER et bien 50% des trains sont
censés circuler en heure de pointe sur
les lignes A et B du RER et la RATP doit
assurer un service de 25% pour les
métros bus et RER bah problème et on l'a
dit le noeud du problème il est là la
loi ne prévoit pas la réquisition des
grévistes pour assurer le service
minimum si la RATP grève c'est pas pour
ce que tu nous dis c'est parce qu'ils
veulent plus de pognon
qu'ils ont peur de la concurrence ils
veulent c'est un problème d'argent et
que ce qui veut dire que pour mieux
payer les agents de la RATP il y a que
deux solutions et soit nous payons plus
d'impôts soit on le répercute sur le
prix de vente de des transports de
solution et je vois pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui dans la problématique
actuelle dans le contexte de notre pays
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui pourquoi en
sollicite aurait les Français
c'est-à-dire nous tous pour dire nous
devons plus payer les agents de la RATP
en a mangé le soleil on a mangé les
étoiles
on a mangé le ciel et on a encore la
terre la langue on va manger la nuit
viens voir tes cartes car après tout on
peut
se nourrir en quelques mots partagés
dans une lettre ouverte Mark Zuckerberg
le patron de Facebook vient de licencier
11000 salariés c'est un des changements
les plus difficiles que nous ayons
connus dans l'histoire de l'entreprise
une coupe majeure conseillée pour la
première fois par le réseau social 13%
des effectifs supprimés le fondateur de
Facebook reconnaît une erreur d'analyse
en ayant trop investi après la pandémie
et pointe des performances financières
décevantes
[Musique]
des licenciements qui ont lieu désormais
au sein de tous les géants de la Silicon
Valley la semaine dernière Elon Musk en
rachetant Twitter mettez-vous en contrat
de près de la moitié des salariés de
l'entreprise
la société de VTC lift devrait licencier
plus de 10% de ses salariés même le
géant Amazon vient de mettre en pause
ses embauches c'est le temps perdu qui
prend le
temps perdu qui prend le dessus alors
pardon oui là jolie prout ouais
[Musique]
je suis ton père
tout le monde est une drôle de personne
et tout le monde à l'âme emmêlé
[Musique]
c'est ça le truc c'est que ça fait
partie des spécificités de candidats il
est fan de hard rock Frédéric il a un
look de harder enfin de hard rocker
pardon
explique-nous un petit peu l'histoire de
ton look parce que il y a quand même une
petite histoire là j'adore acheter en
fait quand j'étais petite et je
m'achèterai plein de choses
elle m'a dit j'ai acheté une moto
[Musique]
à construire un cercueil en béton de
plus d'une tonne pour un paquet de chips
un paquet qui la suspendu pour éviter
qu'un tremblement de terre ne
l'endommage quant au laser il permet
d'éliminer germes et bactéries sur la
pierre tombale il a inscrit les
ingrédients à la feuille d'or le
sarcophage enterré sur un terrain à
Seattle est une capsule naturel une
trace de notre civilisation un ouvrir
que dans 10 000 ans un cadeau
invraisemblable aux générations futures
pour un dernier frisson pour un dernier
âge
pour ranger les souvenirs avant le grand
hiver juste encore une
nuit sans motif et son but puisque ma
vie n'est rien
entière tout à fait dans toutes ses
routes
puisque
ma vie n'est rien